[Applause]
a high-stakes political showdown in the
Mexican Capital has come to an end
[Applause]
bomb former mayor of Mexico City has
been selected as the presidential
candidate for Mexico's ruling Morena
party ahead of the 2024 general election
[Applause]
today democracy won today the people of
Mexico decided
shamebaum's victory was announced just
hours after Marcelo ebrar Mexico's
former foreign minister who came in
second in the polls just behind Shane
bomb called for the candidate selection
process to be annulled and done over
the results could be questionable it's
better to do things right and repeat the
process once more
the selection of Claudia shanebaum a
close Ally of leftist President Andres
Manuel Lopez obrador means she will now
go head-to-head against sochil Galvez a
conservative senator from Mexico's Bond
party whose nomination was announced
just weeks ago and whose Nation campaign
is already growing in support
two months ago we uh we didn't think
that an opposition candidate would
appear with such force and now we have
um
a better face some of us we have a
better face that the election it's going
to be more competitive
though Claudia Shane bomb has now been
officially selected as the party
representative ahead of the national
election there are those within the
morena party who continue to voice
concerns over the way the selection
process was carried out with tensions
still high here in Mexico over the
Integrity of the selection process for
the morena Party candidate political
analysts say that Claudia Shane bomb's
nomination represents a test of unity
for the morena party itself ahead of the
upcoming general election
with the leading candidates firmly
selected the scene is now set for Mexico
to elect its first woman president in
the nation's history with the general
election scheduled for the 2nd of June
2024. Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera Mexico
City
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera